[Musik]
ich glaube es ist er in der malerei ganz
gut aufgehoben der gleichzeitig sein
liebes oder sanftes und rücksichtslos 20
nicht umgekehrt aber seine eltern
glücklich gemacht oder ob er geld
verdient damit
[Musik]
in farbe getränkte folien daniel klinger
setzt sie zu einem kunstwerk zusammen
mehrere wochen manchmal monate arbeitet
er an einem bild
[Musik]
finanziell schaue ich mich weiter als
bis zum nächsten monat gibt's nicht
verbot keine urlaubsreisen
wir sind betrug von altersarmut der lohn
der malerei de liegt in der malerei
selber dass die freiheit haben unser
leben so zu gestalten dass wir das wäre
der sache so liegen dürfen dass sie so
ganz darin aufgehen dürfen liegen dann
ekstasen drinnen und freude die
aufrichtigkeit kommt
[Musik]
richte geld zu vermarkten fällt der
eltinger die vielen bildenden künstlern
schwer
[Musik]
seine bilder sind ab 1500 euro zu haben
die größeren kosten um die 6000 doch
eher verkauft meist nur fünf bis sechs
pro jahr und ist oft gesetzlich auf
sozialhilfe angewiesen
die deutsche hauptstadt berlin 70 jahren
künstler aus aller welt an
[Musik]
wer hier ausstellt hat es geschafft die
galerie eigen und art ist eine der top
adressen in deutschland
galerist gerd harry lybke vertritt maler
stars wie neo rauch und wurde so selbst
die wände der galerie sind leer nur eine
perlenkette liegt auf dem boden wird
teil einer installation die 90.000 euro
kostet konzeptkunst zu der daniel
klinger er zugang finden und daniel
schaut sich gern ausstellung an das
inspiriert ihn doch der kommerziellen
kunstbetrieb bleibt ihm fremd
dabei müsste er eigentlich teil davon
sein
zutage dass viele künstler dafür wer aus
dem vollen schöpfen können sie mehr sind
am festgemacht seiner galerie auch junge
künstler und man fühlt sich zusammen
macht das weil wir nehmen jetzt nicht
auf die künstler auf oder sogar sondern
bei uns ja so dass man sagen könnte
bitte rufen sie uns nicht an rufen sie
an alte wenn uns was hier im team
auffällt oder ein künstler von uns sagt
guck dir das mal dann guckt man sich das
an aber man hat auch gar keine zeit all
die bewerbung und all die dinge die
hereinkommen sich anzusehen
der kunstmarkt ist umkämpft das angebot
viel größer als die nachfrage
ein
[Musik]
daniel quinger verkauft seine bilder
bisher eher zufällig vor allem an
freunde bekannte und einige wenige
sammler
ich glaube das wäre mir gar nicht
möglich
ich war so lange dass sich leichter
verkauft betrachter soll erwarten dürfen
dass das gemälde möglich ist dass ist
nach seinem eigenen werde bedingungen
entwickelt wurde
die freiheit das machen zu dürfen was
ich machen will
diese mir das kostbarste dafür nimmt man
das in kauf dass man nicht so mitmachen
kann mit einem anderen video die
fröhliche setzen